31 men showed up to impress Bachelorette
Rachel Lindsay on Monday night's
premiere a problem that I don't mind
having these are the six standout limo
exits that'll have you laughing make you
smitten or my totally creeped you out
first
Adam who totally brought a creepy doll
because who wouldn't like that
this is Adam jr. okay and he's super
excited just so excited I am to be here
tonight and I'm even more excited on
this journey with you so best the best
of the part is you get two for the price
of one like II really tried drumming up
a creative entrance after his brief
appearance on after the final rose I
feel like my last entrance was a little
less memorable so I wanted to drum up
something new for you and penguin suits
definitely the new shark costume props
to Matt I know you have a thing for
penguins oh yes once penguins find their
soul mates they tend to meet for life
and with any luck I hope that that's me
then there's Jonathan aka
the tickle monster I wanted to make sure
you you had at least one good laugh
tonight Chris Harrison told eg it's not
as weird as it sounds look there's a
very thin grey line when you start
tickling a woman that you really don't
know that well luckily Jonathan walks
that line and instead of the restraining
order Rachel actually finds him very
endearing Samba wobble wah boom it's all
about water it is though there's also
this guy Lucas who might want to whatnot
[Music]
and finally call it G Z or call it smart
but the jury is out we kind of love
fellow attorney
Josiah I am convinced that by the end of
our experience together you will have no
reasonable doubt ha ha ha oh thank you
those girls can you late a litigator
[Music]